the recent euphoria special
which i just watched and i'm curious
when you get
that script and it's so kind of
dense and text heavy and i know your
experiences
in the theater where you're used to
memorizing an entire play worse of
material
i imagine the shooting schedule is a lot
quicker it's during covid it's kind of
last minute
technically what was it like to like
memorize and get your get your lips
around that text
well uh sam first told me about the
episode and he said it's just an episode
which is you and zendaya
and um it's just you two um having a
deep conversation about about life
addiction loss and love
and i said wow so it's just two of us he
said yeah i said could you give me the
script as soon as possible i said
absolutely so he sent me the script and
i think i had about a month
and i put myself into the blessing
of the pandemic is i had time so i put
myself into a full-time rehearsal like i
did in the theater so i probably
rehearsed for about 40 hours
a week for three weeks and i took it
very seriously i
i got up and i rehearsed myself i i put
my lines
on um you know in a program called you
know rehearsal app pro
and i read zendaya's lines i read mine i
listened back and forth
the first week i just listened to the
lines just like sort of listen like
music and let them just get into my
system
and then i would break it down and do my
work i did all the work
that i haven't done for a long time
in the theater the way to build
character to build the moment
so therefore hopefully um the work
doesn't show itself i just want to be
available in the room
once me and zendaya were together so i
put myself through a full-time rehearsal
and um and with even when it comes to
research
and having conversations with uh people
in recovery
um um examining even like the history of
uh black men and why they become uh
muslims as well and what what exactly
does that offer
um anything that was in our text
and i had time to do my research in
detail to find out
what is the relationship between nike
and the black community
what is the relationship between all
these things um
and ali and and what he wants in that
scene and so then
i think we had the opportunity to
actually sam gave us i think we had
five days of shooting and and we knew
our schedule
and the beautiful thing is it was just
two people in a diner so
we got the got a chance to just it had
an ease to it
and because the set was smaller the
production team is smaller
it sort of stripped away the whole
circus of a set
and made it a bit more graceful to be
honest and i think so you can do that
work you can do that work that requires
such um a sense of
peace to just listen and respond to do
that thing
that you know you teach in school you
know i teach
or students are trying to learn which is
actually quite simple
that you go through all these
universities and all to learn how to
listen
and respond and it's actually that
simple and i think what
the day and i truly did and which is why
i think the episode is so special
because it is
watching two people at the end of this
year
do the thing that we're asking people to
do
in the world which is sit across from
one another
and have a hard talk and go to some very
deep places
and don't be afraid of it but to um
put your heart and soul in it because
you want to get closer to that person